[Music]
my family's lived in wendover for almost
300 years we have the beaches and the
breezes and the best damn views on the
north shore of boston it's so beautiful
frank i've been calling you for days
there's a lawyer from boston who's very
interested in your waterfront lot do you
ever answer your phone no
i was a tough broker on the north shore
and if everything had gone according to
plan i'd be fine
that's not what happened hildy would you
like to have a seat well if we're really
gonna do this i need a drink oh my god
i'm kidding
[Music]
my daughters would freak if they could
see me right now don't they want you to
be happy my ex-husband left me for a man
and i went to rehab okay husband will do
that to you juice did that
mom do you think i'm excited to ask you
for money no i'm sure it's very hard
rents mortgages tuitions i need a good
year
what i know it looks bad but in my mind
the wine is not really drinking
vodka definitely is
hey hilly oh frank you were spying on me
i came here for some peace and quiet
uh-huh yeah then i got an eyeful
[Music]
there was a time in my life i was quite
in love with frankie gatchell cute as a
button you would have been too all my
friends were you want to come over for
dinner dinner it's this meal people eat
at the end of the day
it's pretty popular sure
i'm sure mom had been around to play
with us when we were little my mom
didn't do this stuff right the good old
days
[Music]
[Music]
it's okay to be angry and scared it's
okay to ask for help
i'm tired of sweeping everything under
the rug i didn't realize i was doing
that
i feel like myself with you usually i
only feel like myself when i have a
drink in my hand
so you need to do hildy i'm not going
anywhere
my girls really like you
they're good girls
i was talking about my dogs
[Music]